take command of your fleet and set out
to unite the galaxy in sid meier's
starships starships is an adventure
driven strategy game which combines
episodic missions resource management
tactical combat exploration and
spaceship design travel to new worlds
and complete missions on planets across
the galaxy set in the universe of beyond
Earth after the age of the ceding
players take on the role of fleet
commander leading their starships across
the galaxy while making important
decisions managing and building the
world's under their control in this
video we'll introduce you to some of the
systems of Sid Meier's starships and how
you can master them to achieve your
vision of a unified galaxy use energy to
build new ships and modules build your
ships to fill any tactical role from
powerfully armored battle cruisers
bristling with short ranged cannons to
fast laser arm destroyers that strike at
a distance for ad fighter bays turning
your ships into powerful carriers your
Federation scientists can research
upgrades to your starship modules you
can also win a science victory by
unlocking three level 6 technologies use
metals to construct planetary
improvements increasing the yield of
that world or they can be used to build
unique wonders that grant powerful
bonuses to your fleet build seven
wonders and win a wonder victory use
food to start new cities on planets as
the population of the world increases
not only do you come closer to winning
the population victory of 51 percent of
the galaxy but each world is capable of
producing more resources for your
Federation at the heart of the game are
the missions your fleet will undertake
combat missions are turn-based each turn
your ships move and take an action
firing weapons launching fighters or
torpedoes cloaking or sweeping with your
sensors narrow passages can occasionally
open in these asteroid fields allowing
ships and fighters to pass take
advantage of them but be aware that the
enemy
also whose own your ships have a number
of hit points and are knocked out when
these drop below zero critical hits
reduce some modules effectiveness
leaving your ship vulnerable leaving you
with a choice to make either take an
action to repair these critical hits or
use that action to fire on an
unsuspecting target keep in mind you can
repair your starship with energy between
missions but not during the mission
there are also battle cards which can
provide you with bonuses in combat some
battle cards affect single ships for one
turn while rare and powerful ones
benefit the entire fleet for a whole
mission don't overlook these as they may
make the difference between defeat and
glorious victors while your crew are
dedicated long missions can take their
toll as your crew becomes fatigued the
performance of your ships also decreases
a fatigued crew of a powerful fleet can
be wiped out by an enemy they would
easily defeat it rested at some point in
your turn you will need to decide if
your crew needs a rest and shore leave
as you complete missions and special
tasks for worlds you gain influence
sending a crew on shore leave will
increase your influence with that world
by one at the start of your next turn
when you gain 4 influence points with a
planet they will join your Federation
other factions may also try to recruit
the same world to join them you see
competing influences here winning a game
of starships will require more than
tactical success in combat you'll also
need a plan for victory consider how to
use the features of your worlds in
combination with improvements for
example this icy world produces extra
science building the crypto lab here
will be more effective than building it
on another world
operational plan for your victory type
if you have a small Federation with
powerful neighbors you will be able to
win through a science victory if you
have a large number of worlds try for a
population victory there is an entire
galaxy out there waiting for you and
your fleet to defeat threats and bring a
glorious new age to humanity in sid
meier's starships